uh
pete davidson ah pete davis a little
quick five minute video this will be fun
uh pete davidson gives an exclusive tour
of his basement apartment hi
can i just give a disclaimer sure
because i watched this whole thing
before the show
guys you're gonna get angry
just like just warning you well let's
check it out
uh first thing i want to point out is
the fingernails
the painted fingers dude he's so out
there he's artistic
he's creative type man you know he
painted
[Music]
bro he's lighting a blunt dude that's
pretty cool dude
like the thing is like some people won't
go there he goes there like mike you
won't go there
he you won't go there he chronically
goes there
yeah no pun intended guys uh
it's pete davidson uh we are in my
apartment
slash basement in my mom's house in
staten island
i moved here like a year ago and built
this weird little
basement to stay away from [ __ ]
people so i'm about to show you guys
what's up dude he's such a recluse man
he's so cool he's so
such a creative title like he is he does
he can't be around he's a tortured
artist
man i wish he was tortured up down here
he's tortured in a cia black site prison
oh she was i wish he would be tortured
the way uh sheikh khalid muhammad was
[ __ ] tortured
[Music]
you guys gave me this for my special
really great gift
i love guns and roses you couldn't like
yeah i know he doesn't like guns and
roses bro he likes wiz khalifa you want
to know why bro cuz he's black guy
because he's me dude and he thinks he's
black cool guys cool i want to be cool
hang out with the black guys so i could
be cool ask one of my friends
like what does pete want what does he
like uh this is spongebob
i haven't worn this yet because um
it's very yellow uh
[ __ ] you neutered [ __ ] i haven't
worn this yet because i'm not a
would have been funnier right like i
haven't worn this [ __ ] because i'm not
i haven't worn this yet because i'm not
and i'm not still stuck in my youth oh
these are cool these are blockbuster
sweatpants i'm just stealing dvds
oh wait check out this bathroom i got a
porno bathroom with a porno shower
i have no one is that a porno shower it
just seems like a walking shower
i don't watch a lot of shower pouring
can anybody fill me in is that what the
showers look like does it bother you
because it bothers me
the the the layout of the bathroom he
has a tub in front of the
entrance yeah the tub is blocking the
entrance to his shower you're right it's
bothering
me too yeah that's not you could tell
too that yeah i guarantee you i'll bet
you [ __ ] cash money
that the contractor even said are you
sure you want me to put the tub here
because it's
gonna block the the shot and he was like
yeah i don't care i want that tall
dude but nobody's been in except for me
and boys not all at the same time but
i've never had had uh
at my point oh moment who are the boys
i'm there yet it's really hard too too
when your mom's like upstairs like
cooking
and like being like dana's ready and
you're like
oh let me just this are his friends also
uh yeah dude he just hangs out with a
pack of i mean a pack of cool dudes cool
young dudes having a cool fun time in
the porno shower
my favorite favorite thing i have in
here this is called a dust buster and
never seen one of those before pete tell
me what a dustbuster is how do those
work
i do those things have been around since
the beginning of time
what's up dirk but like little dirt you
know like like like this
how [ __ ] sick
how sick is that [ __ ] i mean we had one
of those when i was like
five uh there's a bunch of people
playing video games very quietly
uh it's very uncomfortable here's some
sad [ __ ] you want some dead dad [ __ ]
this is the stuff you guys like
ready here it is uh here's a good
picture of my dad
probably all coked up on a roof
somewhere with his boys
where my dad [ __ ] bro but i'm cool like
i'm aloof about it
like i'm aloof about it i don't even
care that my dad died and it probably
contributed to the fact that i'm a
douche bag now oh here's my other
favorite thing
i got rodney dangerfield's uh thai laney
got his fur by the way pete davidson is
the epitome of a 911 kid and i know
because i
i grew up with a couple 911 kids that
lost their parents in 911 they
all did they ever find him
probably not he turned into dust okay
with the entire building
full of burning jet fuel collapsed on
him um
but this is the problem with 9 11 kids
and he's not the only one there are a
lot of kids i grew up with that were 9
11 kids that
got money they got like spoiled
afterwards
they basically got get out of jail free
cards for the rest of their life for any
abhorrent behavior they engaged in
anything they did that was awful
it was hey go easy on him lost his dad
at 9 11. there's a lot of that that went
around growing up on long island
and he's the [ __ ] epitome of that
it wouldn't fly today it says ronnie
traditionally gives away a tie at the
end of each of his live performances in
exchange
for a kiss from a lovely young lady in
the audience
[Music]
this is my grandfather with judd and me
oh he told me he had parkinson's with
judd you know is there a first name
just hanging out him and judd apatow
[ __ ] hang bro i'd rather hang out
with judd nelson
uh midway through the scene uh that i
put him in he said uh
this director is taking a lot of takes
uh how much longer am i going to be on
set
my parkinson's is acting up and then
jude yelled action and that's how i
found out that my grandfather had
parkinson's
your stories are so interesting tell me
more his stories are her
everything about this guy is so
uninjured he's
so unremarkable and this just keeps
getting pushed down everybody's throat
my boy kevin
[Music]
you have any questions yeah i have some
why are you you why are you famous
why do people defend you why do people
think you're funny
why is lauren michaels [ __ ] lauren
michaels of 20 years ago would have
[ __ ] you out of that place so fast oh
yeah you would have been out of that
place
faster than anybody could you imagine
pete davidson trying to keep up back
when they had like
[ __ ] the the real crew that we grew
up on like uh the will ferrell
will ferrell tim meadows and like
[ __ ] chris kittan and all those guys
he would have been crushed he would have
been destroyed all the women on that era
would
have destroyed him oh yeah by the way i
got to write read this brian quinn in
the chat right he's so hollow it's
almost fascinating that is a great
description of pete davidson
got shaq's shoe when you get on uh
tv people send you things like this and
they're like that was cool
but it's not look where it is look
behind my fake alien kevin
i wish they'd send you a ticking box
wish ted kaczynski would send you a gift
seriously
that's where your shack shoe goes this
is my uncut gem basketball
currently my favorite thing in the cave
do you hear what he called it the cave
bro the cave like a man cave
is he you know what he he he has some
he has a little semblance of jim norton
in him
where it's that like obsession with
the biz the thing i mean like look at my
uncut gems basketball
i got that from uh from sandler's uh
assistant
sent that to me here's my shock shirt
what do you think bro cool huh
the thing is he has a man cave while his
dad's buried in a mass grave
so like everybody has their thing yeah
this dude though man it's like you
shouldn't be this age and still going
like hey
how old is he check out my shoes check
out my cool shoe
this is late 20s by now uh this is my
uncut jam that my buddy dave
bought me but he's a cheap [ __ ] and he
got me a rock
so look what it did to my [ __ ]
who cares that's melanie's jersey i have
that up there because i can't believe
he's my friend
um
this is my wall i have people who come
down here
sign my wall this is my bedroom where
nothing happens because i live with my
mom
oh here are my spongebob collectors and
shoes the only thing is you can't
[ __ ] wear them with anything because
oh he's really into spongebob stuff huh
this is but like
all right we got to go back to the this
thing here he's 26.
he has a closet right he has a closet
that we saw
why does he have racks of shoes in his
bedroom isn't that just childlike
like it just doesn't go with anything
pete davis would be really cool if i was
like 11 brian quinn says
too much clothes much shoes in the room
like what are you doing
it works starbursts shirts
[Music]
i'm sure there's more this is an eddie
murphy
party all the time original vinyl and i
like it
because it reminds me uh that i will
never be as cool as eddie murphy
we agree you'll never be as funny or as
talented as him or have a success
this is what i always that's what i
always meant because whenever we talk
about pete davidson
there's a lot of people that defend him
oh dude a weird amount a weird amount of
people defend pete davidson
but they're girls that [ __ ] bums that
remind them of pete david's right they
could change him and stuff like that
but this is what i always ask because
people he's great he's the best part of
snl i hear that all the time
but if i were to name it let's name the
greats because they treat him like he's
an snl great so let's let's say
if i were to go will ferrell you can
name like three characters off the top
of your head
that will ferrell played i mean it
should be like that boom
tim meadows you could name tim meadows
as carol oh tim meadows ladies man
bam you know stuff like even chris
parnell like
there's certain people you can name and
go oh yeah you know he was this guy or
he was that guy
i could kill i could kill him in two
words phil
hartman yeah exactly you're done you're
fired pete
phil harper pretending to be a caveman
it's funnier than anything you've ever
done in your entire life by the way that
sketch sucked but phil hartman was so
good but he made it so great because it
really was a badly written
of course but he was so good at it and
the makeup was so good
but name right now anybody in the chat
name
right now a famous
pete davidson character he always plays
pete davidson
exactly the pete davidson guys he's pete
davis just self
referencing people saying even jay moore
even jake by the way is a [ __ ]
douchebag
and he's not funny now even jay moore is
funnier than [ __ ] pete davidson
jaymore has made me laugh pete davidson
has never made me laugh not once
look at that oh wait jay's getting a
tattoo let's see how it's coming out
what are you getting survive making sure
it's spelled right
yeah tattoos right in the house in his
house yeah dude
get tattoos we got we're just chilling
man
all of these dudes look like they hang
out with david bond
like it's no it's this weird like
[Music]
hangout spot and you people think this
is cool
yes these are you're right the people
that defend pete davidson are girls that
do molly in a guy's house
like not in a music festival no they do
it but in his couch
they look like they should be hanging
out on nacho's couch and [ __ ] better
call saul
that's what they look like the kind of
girls that just wake up with a hangover
at the corner and eboard and you're like
oh my god who's
come is in me exactly except it's pete
davidson waking up and saying oh my god
who's
coming to me oh
do you ever want to show the tattoo that
i gave you i'd rather know
it's not even that you have a bunch of
tattoos you have a bunch of shitty
prison tats yeah they're all garbage
yeah i think it's pretty great
look at that that's not bad why are your
fingernails painting painted i don't
understand
cause he this is a guy he's
he's he's peacocking this is just women
do it men do it this is
this is what you do when you have
developed
zero talent personality genuine
interests
like a life like a life um
you it's that that's what life is life
is your
your interests and the things you like
and the things that make you you he
doesn't have anything like that so it's
just i'll paint my nails and get neck
tattoos
i need something i also did a [ __ ]
on giulio ah [ __ ]
this is stuff that you do when you're 16
years old like i'm being
serious like this stuff you do [ __ ]
you hang out with your [ __ ] friends
go wouldn't it be crazy
i'm going to pop this pen open and give
me a needle i'm going to tattoo you bro
it's it is but again this is what your
typical
9 11 kid acts like like a lot of them
are like this i know a lot of people
um a couple i went to school with that
they got a bunch of money
they got like i know one guy got a truck
he got a whole bunch of night he blew
all the money that they gave him from
the
from the 911 money and then he was like
getting duis and he was doing drugs and
selling
he just became a degenerate but every
time he got in trouble people were like
nah man go easy on his dad died in 911
and you're like okay i get it but it's
2009
now you know like at what point do you
just go all right enough
anyway thank you guys for stopping by my
crib come back again what was the point
to piss us off well that yeah you pay me
again to do another special
that's a really good point someone goes
and in staten island like he lives in
staten island on top of everything
thank you guys for checking this out and
uh i'm excited for you guys to see
the special i've been doing santa for
like 10 years
now in fact it was my 10-year
anniversary was like a week
27 so he started doing stand-up when he
was 17. god before
you're so bad at this i'm super duper
stoked on this and i just uh
yeah i feel good about it i don't
haven't felt good about a lot of [ __ ]
you shouldn't feel pretty good about
this one yeah you shouldn't
you shouldn't you shouldn't feel good
about it i can't wait for the new pete
davidson special
can you it's already out on netflix and
netflix has been pushing it it's like
one of the main thing that pops up when
you log in
it's one of the main things wow and i
haven't heard
any buzz about it so that's not a good
sign the only thing that you heard from
it was when he told the louis ck
story that's where the louisiana yeah
but that's even that it's not i'm not
hearing that
from real people i'm hearing that on
[ __ ] l.a podcasts by brendan schaub
and brian cowan
right are you here are any of your
friends coming up to you and going royce
yo if you were repeat david said about
louis c bro you guys see that special
it's fun
nobody's saying that